the nevada gop is once again alleging
voter fraud in the 2020 election
and in a new lawsuit announced just this
afternoon
it now joins a list of others filed in
recent weeks despite no evidence of
widespread voter fraud
erko manor breaks down this latest legal
challenge
this is the fifth lawsuit the nevada gop
and the trump team have filed
they continue to claim that there was
major voter fraud in the 2020 election
despite providing no concrete evidence a
lawyer for the trump campaign
even saying president trump won in
nevada we are
asking the court to recognize the fact
that president trump was victorious in
this election
contesting the election results that's
the goal of the trump campaign's latest
lawsuit filed tuesday afternoon in
carson city district court but final
numbers show joe biden beat president
trump by nearly 35 thousand votes in
nevada the legal challenge largely
includes allegations we've heard before
including that more than 15 thousand
people voted both in nevada
and another state voters who are listed
as dead voted
and the signature verification machine
in clark county was not reliable
this all comes back to the
unsubstantiated claim that nevada's
expanded mainland voting system resulted
in irregularities
we had a lot of improper ballots being
mailed to people's homes and apartment
buildings
nevada and clark county have created
this crisis reckless
unsolicited mail-in voting
has created this crisis the nevada
secretary of state who by the way is a
republican has consistently said there
is no evidence of widespread voter fraud
clark county officials also releasing a
statement saying in part the trump
campaign is quote
parroting erroneous allegations made
bipartisans without firsthand knowledge
of the facts
it's important to note that most of the
other lawsuits and legal challenges
filed by the trump team
have been rejected by the courts there
is one case currently pending
in federal court reporting in las vegas
orca mana 8 news now